yo welcome to this video this is a
15-minute game yes a rapid game slower
paced add a little bit more time to
explain things let's see what's going on
here good Kings Indiana playing Illya
are ileana let's let's see here alia no
I've actually got a picture and they're
okay but no name he's playing mostly
standard and wrap it so long time
control specialist here no blitz games
okay yeah probably you five and then it
is White's choice what line to play i
recently tried out them and line here
with 99 to d2 it's a very solid line and
aimed at securing the center a5 is a
more prophylactic move em with a five
black invests a move to stop before for
the moment and yeah and it's a little
bit more time now to get this going root
b 1 b form it takes a move but also it
weakens the queenside a little bit so it
gains time but we can see structure very
often a5 signals yeah exactly black the
intention to play something like this
which is more unfocused on stopping why
its activity or slowing it down then
starting a wild attack on the King side
we're going to see what happens yeah hmm
c6 this is a this is an interesting way
to play unfortunately also a way to play
that I have not studied I only recently
looked a bit at this line but
I did not yet count to come to this come
to this line this will be one now
probably would be one there should be
two of those two moves I think I played
but I'm not sure ya see six is a is a
very interesting way to play black ass
yeah shifting his attention to the Queen
side and in some lines i think black can
even play b5 I don't think this is one
of them but okay as usual the move is
played right after I say it's probably
not possible well okay I didn't say it's
impossible address I was just thinking
this is some not the line yeah the idea
is that after C takes us already takes
c6 black will play before yeah do I have
an alternative not really he will play
before probably in any case so let's go
for that after be form how am I going to
play this it's interesting mmm
I can take on before a be a be I mean
taking on d 7 as the first move but
takes on serious awkward so that's not
going to be any good I have to move the
night 95 90 x c 6
hmm interesting I can also it's not so
easy to say if I should trade on before
or not I can also awesome some also
argue about night on to be five or d5 ok
I'm going to play 95 sorry difficult to
say actually how to play that night x is
six now is pretty much forced I think
yeah ok at least I got one right one of
those I think this is forced the kind of
comments ok I think hmm yeah it should
be two problem it's not the greatest
square ever for this Bishop looking at
this porn but it's a little bit of a
case of where else ok so and let's go
here maybe I get an 8x before it is
rebooting this night possibly to see 5
ok so
what i can do all alone i'm not sure if
it is a good idea i can take before it's
what i'm getting at a Bab ruka aids
queen a 897 one night takes is sex
that's an interesting transformation
okay I'm going for that I'm not sure
that it is that grade I mean that's the
wrong expression but let's say I'm not
sure if it is really leading to an edge
black of course also can do okay Bishop
b5 is not a good move I thought Bishop
g5 cd5 night before but I have moves
like neither Bishop b5 then all night
see form and my play on the light
squares is very very good night x before
however is a move or would have been a
move that is some possible I wonder
actually let's do this I wonder if
Bishop g4 is a move Bishop g4 f5 97's
the tactic is the key tactic Bishop g4
txtx Queen Noor matts i am taking d7
it's an interesting move let's try that
really a key point is that after f5 am
playing 97 and this is a very very
awkward fog and well I'm threatening to
take e cigs and play 97 winning I guess
yeah okay
take and now I'm immediately attacking
the night here the important thing is
this is a temple so he really has to be
I ok so this is of course quite nice let
me take him or is there another move the
move Queen to f3 is also very
interesting just attacking f6 and try
and you try to provoke him chatima let's
let's play it in a very simple way there
ok one getting them they're open file I
have a nice structural advantage here
his bishop on f6 is on those dark
squares and this is not really where it
wants to be he might play Bishop g5 but
ok the queen is is simply not doing
anything there on g4 oh he allows me to
take that
hmm
okay yeah if my night is moving before
is hanging so huh okay I can't capture
play Queen f34 queen d 3
hmm ok I need I need the night somewhere
else okay if I take take winner three
days Bishop g5 actually that's quite
awkward hmm ok I'd really like to take
but I'm still unsure if it's really a
good idea ok but I don't have to take
immediate play not at all still if four
is always hanging I would really like to
play Knight f1 is 325 this would be
excellent or the night after a possible
capture on d4 rerouted to d3 that also
is some would be would be excellent
hmm not easy if I go f3 here like f3
night everyone and he puts the bishop
it's not clear that he can actually my
drop bag hmm yeah f3 is lucky doesn't it
doesn't really help me how do I play
that if you take them Bishop g5 this is
kind of kind of problematic they don't
get the night to a decent square after
the cap Shaun T form
not so easy to play maybe I should have
reconsidered Quincy for the Queen g4
move does have some drawbacks quite
clearly
hmm
don't see them really great way forward
what if i play Bishop d40x Quinby one
controlling d3 intending Knight f3 1d
three ok I have to play a move my
feeling that's really no question yeah
that looks Ted unnatural but the idea is
possibly queen d three if he goes Bishop
g5 I play Knight f3 with an important
temple keeping e4 covered attacking on
g5 and if he plays Luke a8 well okay
that's not really bothering me that much
ok I'm I can take
and I can take possibly and appreciate
let's do this first and they have to
make sure that there's no oh no tactic
hitting here I mean tactic is wrong word
but something like Queen a one that he
invades here with with activity i can't
play with like g3 general improving and
maybe and make sure that I'm am safe in
terms of the back rank one issue here
might be that he may be can invade some
how to add c3 or this kind of thing
would be awkward
oh he's just just giving this up
for bishops III I guess
yeah that does make some sense okay
that's very little choice and taking it
I have to take it Jeff now is it is
awkward to the bishop is strong how do i
coordinate this not easy
I can maybe I can put the nut queen on
b1 no it's got this chick coming and
then you will attack it but i always
have quinchu know why do I put that why
do I put this Queen 8 us coming I've
quindi one though to keep it protected
so probably hear that it's not so easy
to play I mean I absolutely have to
avoid to lose their be three Pawn a
bunch at porn I'm immediately gone when
you attack if he attacks b3 now I'm
going to put my queen on d1 which we are
protected
yeah maybe I can fend off this temporary
activity if this is possible then I
would be our being really good shape
okay so i can take that
I'm not sure not sure this is helping
you I I don't need to I have other ideas
for example night e 1 2 D 3 maybe I
should have taken actually that was that
was stupid I could have taken and then
night you want to see too well it would
have been very easy right ha ok he has
to bottom that was a stupid move plate
the plate too quickly
okay he has no way to attack anything
here so we can't hear doesn't lead to
much to go to hear why do I am how do i
activate the night sorry
hmm Jack can also just take it but
that's not really that convincing Chad
bath the stupid app could have just I
could have just um I really I could have
just taken taken the Queen I don't want
to take your name
look scandal yet I know Quinn Jeff 3122
it when I have 3 i'm also covering my
weak spots and i can maybe activate from
them no probably not
joshua of traded on c3r was much easier
a lot easier
now i'm in and some time issues maybe we
should be five now for him okay but i
can't even go back to f1 it's not a
problem but Queen are three covers the
key squares efore be three takes content
in Jedi can always return okay it feels
it's slightly shaky all this
h.5 might be on
we are now night g3 then h5 is the idea
h5 immediately no h5 immediately is
going to check so I just get the night
out and then possibly age five Bishop g5
might be a move
two minutes 11 that's the biggest
problem I'd like to get rid of this this
week pawn okay when the night is going
to check on edge too it's not a very
dangerous check and I can go to f/11
that's not helping
DRA offered now i'm not going to draw
him yeah i know i am down on time but
design position is rather good so let's
do i want you still want to try to win
yeah it's difficult though definitely is
122
yeah how how can you even try to win
here takes context with Queens on it's
always this perpetual some are the big
issue
DRA offered
I'm very difficult to to go forward but
I simply don't drawing it in a position
that's probably winning even with the
time being an issue I still want to try
to win
check
hey Jim she's very very difficult
objectively to trying to win him
check it's probably even even a
perpetual write checks bra Alfred
laughs that's again if it's a bit insane
but okay 36 seconds check
it's got no check now but the problem is
that some chem I don't have anything
great either if you just take c5 I
probably then have to play Queen e5 and
and check myself
Jeff Jeff draw offered check check Queen
f2 he gets his draw after check now okay
I tried everything check check ha ha and
now I have to gain drama job cause I
have to win this game Joyce really
really bad I can just take on c3 and
sister this is the main problem this is
the main issue we've been would have
been rather easy this position I really
must win there is no way around that i
hack Wendy 54 strong here threatening c5
and and over yeah that that's winning
very straightforwardly actually he has
to move him ok but ok this is I just
kept things and now I can just take I
can just take it and resins basically
here i can i can get to see two and then
the bonus is going ok wow that's very
very easy yeah I was always thinking
beforehand ok I have to be cautious with
Quincy free that I don't take give him
this pawn but right now I'm on f3 and
precisely here I can of course take
because this is such a safe blockade
will easily win the pawn at the end and
this is ok very easy just a pawn and
the better structure with his pawns
completely off that was a very simple
win okay what i did also should win but
it gets it gets tricky with the time the
time ticking down yeah yeah you have to
have to trade quite clearly Jim okay we
had chat this little intermezzo
challenge very improve this is still
possible to do something here it's a
draw I'm but okay I had to had to play
some Queen d3 f3 I probably have to
shuffle reshuffle this but it's not not
at all easy by now check and yet is it
is just objective shared wrong check
HERE Queen f6 each added which went for
this and now okay I can take with the
pawn on d6 and win okay which is what I
did so what was the same problem I went
here jack I have to go to us so i can
just go to g400 that's it ah oh yeah
that's that's very stupid okay 29
seconds i don't know maybe i can maybe i
can do that it's really easy now the
king is safe here this converts
completely safe and I'm just pushing
this this is home okay check yeah check
this is the draw okay with 20 seconds
mmm yeah I can go back here instead and
try to continue I still have this the
sea porn but of course I'm I missed my
chance is some much earlier so yeah we
are trading down into this end
game is kind of questionable and well d
3 I don't know if this is a good idea I
think after that white is just winning
so I don't know I understand that you
wanted to activate the bishop but it's
probably probably not doing him much
good it is really the colonization is
not it's not sufficient really yeah but
i didn't manage to her to win it at the
end ok thanks for watching